[Music]
hi everybody so my name is Lauren Baker
and I'm a multidisciplinary artist so
that means I use a plethora of different
materials and surfaces to create my
artworks and this session is all about
you guys so I'm gonna give a really
quick like background so you can see
like the kind of things that I've made
but more importantly how did I get to
that point and where as in this creative
flow state that I call blue sky thinking
now there's something called the
creativity myth people some people
believe that you know creative people
have this like god-given talent of
creativity and other people say I
haven't got creative born in my body and
I really I was I was brought up in you
know that and by the way that's bollocks
and basically you know creativity is in
it in every single human and it's just
about you know not everybody's had the
opportunity to express themselves and so
this is all about kind of the steps and
the creativity triggers to how it all
evolved now my journey I'm started when
it started eight years ago when I was at
doing a degree in business and with
psychology and sociology and then I did
seven years in the corporate world and I
got to this point where I felt really
disillusioned and I was searching for
the meaning of life and it led me to
pick up a book called the power of now
has anyone heard of that book career
amazing I'm happy to say a lot of people
have so for me the first trigger was a
voiceless book and as soon as I can it's
about living in the present moment and
as soon as I turned the last page of
that book I just knew that I had to quit
my job and so I quit my job the next day
and I knew I needed to like free up my
space and my patterns and being in a new
state so I decided to go to South
America very so
li and within a few days I was I found
myself in South America and a couple of
weeks into the trip I was off the coast
of Rio because this beautiful island
called florianópolis and I found myself
there and everywhere was covered in
mosaics like the floor the lampposts the
bins it was like crazy so I found the
person responsible and it was an amazing
woman Caudill is under and she had a
street art project called wall to wall
love and I joined her street art project
and I started creating mosaics and I had
him that was 28 at the time I hadn't
made any art since I was 16 at school
and I I I got an F Iraq but I didn't I'm
from Middlesbrough and I'm from one of
the worst council estates in
Middlesbrough and it just art just
wasn't really in my field it just wasn't
really it didn't seem available I had a
belief system that it was for super rich
people or super talented people but I
didn't really it didn't feel like it was
an option for me
so I didn't you know hadn't dropped in
but when I was traveling and also I
didn't love drawing and I still don't
love it I do it as part of my art
sometimes but it's not my favorite thing
it takes me a long time and so um mmm I
got to this point where I'm I was in I
was in Brazil and I started smashing up
these mosaics and I was making this
street art and it and I realized I was
like the happiest I'd felt in years and
it still didn't fully thinking but I
just knew I was really happy and I went
on the rest of my journey and three
months later I found myself deep in the
Peruvian Amazon and I started meditating
this is me and Bolivia actually on the
salt flats and I started meditating more
and more and I met some Sherman's and I
was deep in the jungle and I took part
in ceremonies and it was at this point
where I felt this real opening and this
higher consciousness and I felt like I
had this epiphany where I saw my true
soul path and I knew that was an art
was a very sudden in annoying and it was
like creativity freedom expression times
100 and this like real self belief and
that I am an artist even though I had
nothing to show off myself like some
really messy smashed up tiles on on the
streets of Brazil so I researched
where's the best place to study mosaics
because it was my own experience and and
that was in Venice so I'd actually spent
all my money by this point in South
America and I had just enough money to
pay for this one-week course and then I
went on like sofa surfing calm and
stayed on a stranger's couch and did
this little course and just came back
and announced that I was an artist with
this belief and and then it's like you
know eight years later but these are my
people these are my key creativity
triggers so I'm I'm traveling I'm
meditating I'm chasing sunsets some
crazy electricity going on with the
screen and and I broke free from my job
and when I came back I I went on some
courses as well because I thought well
you know this is a whole new thing so I
want to get some some skills as well so
I did I was really interested in an LP
and in coaching so I did some free
taster coaching courses and and and kind
of like helps coach myself through the
creative journey so I want to talk about
so there's some of my creativity
triggers now there's a study that says
that there's there's a place that people
are like the most creative and do you
think it is in when you're on the toilet
when you're in the shower or when you're
cooking anyone know correct
yeah it does anyone want to shout out
any of the places or or things or books
or anything that they're like they're
noise their creativity creativity
trigger nice massage table anyone else
bed nice amazing when you drive in I'm
56
nice cool we'll have time to explore
this further later so a little fact did
you know that you people it's the
studies show that people have between 50
and 80 thousand thoughts a day so that's
over 2,000 thoughts an hour and the
National Science Foundation and they
believe it's about 60 thousand a day and
eighty percent of them are negative and
95% of them are repetitive now I really
want to like induce the positive mindset
where you're feeling really relaxed and
really free so that all the creativity
dots can can join and you can spark some
fresh ideas in this kind of relaxed
flowing state of being that I call blue
sky thinking so if you're up for it I
want to share with you something that I
do in my practice and it's a
visualization where we tap into our
creativity
so I invite you all to just give your
bodies a little shake and just relax and
close your eyes this is going to be five
minutes of your time and I want you all
to take in some really big deep breaths
just shrug your shoulders and feel
yourself relaxing breathing deeply with
every fiber and molecule in your body
feeling the seeds of creativity growing
so will you give yourself permission to
unlock your creativity to unlock your
confidence power freedom and expression
and I want you to visualize what your
dream creative project is now just open
your eyes and scribble down one sentence
that summarizes what that dream creative
project is you've got one minute to just
jot that down okay now just keep that
creative dream in your mind and I'm
going to share some creativity tips with
you and then we're going to come back to
that dream okay so so for me I'm I've
been exploring my creativity triggers
and you've seen it in the images of me
doing my Kundalini Yoga traveling the
world chasing sunsets I'm in nature I'm
reading my inspirational books and these
I know and my creativity triggers that
allow me to open the space up for
everything to flow and for me to feel
that like blue sky thinking so you know
for me it's like it's a it's a its
locations it's a travel adventure it's a
book and it might be you might want to
tune into like your senses and which of
the senses are triggering you and then
you need to you need to know what your
own triggers are so that you can have
more of them in your life now there's a
book that everybody should read because
everybody is an artist and it's called
the artists way by Julia Cameron and
it's my favorite creativity work of all
is anyone read it brilliant amazing
so in the book she talks about two key
things one is the morning pages so we've
heard already that we have up to 80,000
thoughts a day so we want to mind dump
those thoughts in three pages of a4
pages of not taking your hand your pen
off the paper just writing even if
you're writing
this is boring I don't have time for
this but then you get to page three
about halfway down and I promise you the
golden nuggets will come and you'll have
this these great sudden insights that
come from nowhere because you've just
dumped all your thoughts you've just
cleared the way you've just made space
so this is a practice that I took on
from Julia Cameron and I I really wrote
it and then also she does these artist
dates so she says that the artist is an
inner child and we have to nurture it
take care of it and feed it we need to
feed it with images and inspiration in
in all of creativity's forms whether
it's you know poetry dancing reading
writing art galleries everything just
feed the inner artist so sometimes I've
been doing international shores and solo
shows and I'm super busy with
commissions and installations and my
friends ring me and say hey what you up
to do you want to hang out and I'm like
oh I'm going to the tit and I like oh
cool can I come and I'm no sorry I'm
going on an artist date with myself and
they're like okay that's pretty weird
but you know it's like I need that
personal time one-on-one where I'm just
really like playing with my inner child
artists and it's also important to spend
time with friends too but so the artist
dates have been really key in my opening
of my creativity another thing that I
found really useful is technology and I
really use technology to help support my
creativity so I get really organized and
I have an idea and you know as anyone
read the book I'm big magic by Elizabeth
Gilbert about how you get an idea you've
got to capture it quickly before it's
gone so I capture my IDs and I quickly
put them on Trello otherwise they lost
and I forgotten them really quick does
anyone use Trello
and there's other organization apps as
well but there's and then another thing
is like Pinterest so it's you know
gathering all these images and also does
anyone use Instagram yeah so you know I
I see my social media feed and and my
fashion and everything that I do is just
another exciting opportunity to express
my creativity so I like my my Instagram
free to be quite curated but I also
don't want to spend a lot of time over
it so I use plan early and that's an app
that I just really fast just like put it
all in and everything's looking all
creative and flowing okay so I'm really
using technology to like help things
just be flowing and easy and then I'm
also filling my my feed
whether it's my social media feed or my
life with people who inspire me like I'm
constantly listening to audible I'm
always multitasking I'm making are I'm
running to meetings and I'm always
listening to motivational speakers like
Tony Robbins and Adam Robinson and
Marianne Williamson and so many others
but I'm constantly on the go and I'm
listening and I'm taking everything in
and if this if it isn't inspiring me
delete I'm cutting it so I'm choosing
what comes into my life and then if
there's anyone here that really isn't
clear on what their what their passion
is yet and I mean it took me to age 28
and and I had to go on some pretty
extreme adventures and journeys and and
find myself in the Peruvian Amazon to
find my true inner calling and find my
passion and you know we don't all have
those opportunities to be able to crouch
jobs and everything but what you can do
is if you're ever in doubt about what is
my passion what is my creative path tune
into what you really love doing when you
were like 5 years old
and there's some secret keys there to
unlock so for example when I think about
what I loved you when I was five I was
like like running around the garden
finding like little treasures of like
shiny little objects so I was you know
and I was collecting them and I was
putting them in little boxes I was
texting my treasures and I was and I
another thing I love doing is riding my
bike and I'm around that time eight
years ago when I was feeling really
disillusioned and searching for the
meaning of life I started to think about
well what makes me happy and he was just
very simple going back to like when I
was five and I was like I really like
riding my bike I'm gonna buy myself like
a really cool bike so I've got a nice
bump to bike and my favorite color
turquoise and I'm riding around I get
all like not all lots and lots of my
inspiration when I'm riding my bike you
know it's just simple steps that lead
you on the right path so and it might be
that you like to climbing trees and you
realize you need to be in nature or
might be that you liked making mud pies
and you need to be a chef there's little
little secrets so you've seen my dream
it's to be an artist and I love what I
do and I've been after being an artist
for seven years I kind of like tuned in
again and was meditating and thinking
you know is am I going to be an artist
my entire life
because every every seven years every
cell in your body is rejuvenated any
like a whole new person so and my
journey has gone kind of like education
for seven years you know seven years in
the workplace seven years an artist and
I wanted to check in and be like is this
still is this still my path or should I
be working for charities or what's
what's the what's the thing and it was
and I joined in and I got a message that
it's a hundred percent my path till the
day I die and I can do all those other
things and one of the things I wanted to
do was inspire other people to be
creative because I was pretty lost
before I found my creativity
and I'm really happy and I love what I
do and it doesn't feel like work so
that's my passion and that's why I'm
here today so just to finish um there's
a study that I found like so inspiring
and it's um it's a nurse who worked in a
terminally ill ward of a hospital and as
people were passing they she noticed the
same five regrets coming up again and
again and there was and she found that
it was an actual thing and so she did
this official study with a thousand
people who were on their deathbed and
this same regrets came up and I think a
few of them are really relevant for this
creativity talk right now
and I think number one was I wish I'd
lived a life true to myself not what
others wished for me another one was I
wish I hadn't worked so hard and another
one was I wish I'd let myself be happier
so we still have time so it's really
about I'm finding your own personal
creativity triggers and turning on your
blue sky thinking and from this place
your creativity will fly for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you